uh start recording i will do an
intro um and
uh can you guys see me or no
yeah okay so
uh eve are you ready to go i'm ready
awesome
well everybody it is a treat to have dr
e vava diacus who is uh who was a
uh provost diversity fellow and phd
candidate
in the physics department at cornell
university but she needs to update her
webpage
because she's now a phd she is now an
official
uh post post doctoral
she is now a postdoctoral scholar i
believe
and we're going to learn more about her
research in
uh in cosmology in in particular looking
at distant galaxies and using the
atacama
cosmology telescope the uh act pole
receiver
and looking for both the uh the thermal
and
kinematic sennyi of zeldovich effects
and
fun fact for eve she may not know i had
two advisors in graduate school one was
alexander palmerev who's a russian
scientist
and his phd advisor was yaakov
borosevich
and he was an amazing scientist who
would say really funny things that i
learned about like when
i was trying to do too many things at
once alex would say in the name of jakob
zeltova she would say brian
nine women cannot have baby in one
month and i never really knew what that
meant
uh but anyway uh it is uh such a delight
to have uh such a erudite scholar
joining us today
talk about her research this is an
episode of the podcast that i call
journal club you get to see what real
live scientists do
when they're in the laboratory and doing
analysis
really work on new models of how the
universe works and there's no one better
to learn about
than dr evagiacas so eve it's such a
pleasure and delight to have you here
congratulations again and i can't wait
to hear today's presentation
oh gosh thank you so much for that
wonderful introduction um
it's wonderful to be here digitally with
all of you and
yeah i'll be talking about my work
measuring the scenarios
effects this work was the effort of many
of us here at the cornell physics and
astronomy departments
as well as the act collaboration so
thank you to
everybody who is a part of it um i'll
start with some
overview of the sc effects and of course
we're looking at the cosmic microwave
background here
so this is relic radiation from about
380
000 years after the big bang and it's
highly isotropic but it contains these
anisotropies that we see when we
boost our color scale and look at these
small fluctuations in the light
and today we'll be talking about
secondary anisotropis
and these are what we call the
fluctuations that were encoded
after the surface of last scattering
when the photons from the cmb are
traveling through the matter
in our universe before reaching us here
on earth today
so in this image here you can see how
we're looking back
both in time to the cmb and through
structure to the cmb
so these early fluctuations encode
information about the universe as it was
early in the universe's history but also
what happened to it
as it passed through all this data this
is from the sdss boss sdss survey and
that's actually the data set that i'll
be
talking about in our work in this talk
so these secondary anisotropies you can
even see some of them by eye
here are some little sub maps from
sacred ness's paper
in uh covering the act data set that
co-adds data from plonk with maps from
act into these map products that we use
to measure the sc effects
so you can take a look at these and see
little astrophysical sources popping up
as bright spots
as well as shadows of galaxy clusters
appearing
these shadows of the galaxy clusters
that is the tsarnaev zlavic effect
that i'll be describing in the next few
slides
so secondary anisotropies contain rich
astrophysical information that we're
interested in studying
in its own right to learn about the
physics of the structures in our
universe
and they can also contaminate our
primary anisotropy measurements so if
we're looking at
excellent constraints like we're doing
right now in the field and pushing for
in the future
for cosmology we need to be able to
constrain
these understand them and then remove
them when appropriate for making our
measurements
these panels show the three frequencies
of the coated data set
with act and punch data these are at
about 100 gigahertz 150 and 220
gigahertz
you can see that act having this larger
mirror
enables these high resolution
measurements that you can see these
clusters appearing by eye and they're
absent in plonk so each of these panels
is the same little patch of sky and you
can't see those galaxy clusters in plunk
but when you co-add them
you get the benefits of both of the
experiments
and so the center panels are the
co-added data that we then work with for
our measurements
in in this paper that i'll be discussing
later and i also like to point out that
in the essay effect and by the way i'm
assuming you can see my cursor moving is
that a correct assumption yeah okay
great
um in the sc effect in the in the
thermal sc effect you see a null at
around 220 gigahertz and i think it's
neat just by eye
you can see those little galaxy clusters
disappear at that frequency
so i said the word cluster a whole bunch
i'll be talking about galaxy groups
and clusters and halos a lot over the
course of this talk
so when i'm talking about these these
are gravitationally bound collections of
galaxies
there's no sharp distinguishing cutoff
between groups and clusters
but clusters are more massive than
groups and contain more galaxies
these structures grew out of initial
fluctuations in the very early universe
and they contain both dark matter and
baryonic matter
you can think of them in terms of this
assumed profile where you have a higher
density in the center and then it falls
out with some characteristic
function of radius and recent
measurements have found that the
baryonic content
of these halos is less than we would
expect this is the
missing baryons problem we think that
this baryonic matter
is lying more in this warm hot
intergalactic medium
and so we're interested in studying the
baryon content of these
galaxy group and cluster halos we're
able to measure the spatial distribution
of the gas
in these groups and clusters using the
sc effects
and so in this talk i'll talk about how
we could potentially use the tse effect
and the ksc effect to learn about the
baryon content
of groups and clusters and when we
learned about that we'll learn more
about where the matter in our universe
is lying
the kse effect is also going to tell us
about how these structures are moving
around in the large scale structure of
our universe
and we can also gain insight into the
feedback mechanisms that are
driving the evolution of these galaxies
so we can learn about the astrophysics
that play there
so the sinaizadovich effects again are
secondary anisotropy
they're caused by the cmb photons coming
in inverse compton scattering off of the
electrons
that are present in gas especially that
that's grouped into these clusters
and groups and in these halos you can
see them
as a shadow at certain frequencies that
we observe at at these smaller arc
minute scales
the reason we see a shadow is because if
you plot the blackbody spectrum
of the cmb in blue here and you look at
what happens to it when a photon comes
in
and shifts that blackbody spectrum up
because of the
energy that's in the electrons that
scatter these photons
the spectrum is shifted such that if you
observe at about 220 like i pointed out
in that panel earlier
you see no change in the intensity of
the cmv
in that spot but if you look at
frequencies below about 220 gigahertz
you see a decrement
this decrement is why you've been seeing
shadows plotted
if we were to observe above about 220
gigahertz you would see an increment
instead
so the thermal sc effect has a
temperature shift which is proportional
to the integrated electron pressure
along the line of sight you can express
the change in temperature of the cmb
due to the interactions with this gas as
a function of observation frequency
times the compton y parameter you can
think of the constant y parameter
as being an expression that gives you
the number of photon scatterings in the
gas
times the energy gain per photon
scattering
it takes into account the thompson
scattering cross section as well as the
line of sight integral over
the electron number density and the
temperature
of that those electrons in the gas
it's proportional then to the halo
optical depth which is the line of sight
integral over the electron number
density
and takes into account the thompson
scattering cross section
you can think about optical depth as
being a measure of how
likely it is that a photon is going to
be scattered by that gas so if you have
an optically thin
gas and taus is smaller then you'd have
a lower likelihood of interaction
whereas if you have an optically thick
gas you're more likely to scatter those
photons
when we look at compton y it's a proxy
for the mass of
the halo so larger compton y larger
halos
tend to be more optically thick larger
tau so that's how things
scale there we're also interested in
studying the kinematic sc effect
this has a temperature shift now which
is due to
the bulk electron line of site velocity
rather than the temperature of the gas
so it has a proportionality to the line
of sight momentum
of the gas that we're looking through
you can express the temperature
change due to the ksc effect in terms of
tau in this approximation again tau is
the optical depth
of this gas and the velocity so
a photon from the cmb comes in interacts
with that gas it's moving around
in the large scale structure of our
universe if the gas is moving away from
us along the line of sight
you'll see a red-shifted photon whereas
if a if a photon comes in and interacts
with
gas it's moving towards us it'll give it
a kick in energy due to that velocity
and we'll see a blue shifted photon
these lines towards one another show the
pairwise motion of these galaxies
in this talk i'll be discussing the
pairwise estimator approach to measuring
the koc effect
there are a number of ways you can
measure velocities but we look at this
pairwise motion
which tells you how quickly these
objects are moving towards
one another
if you look in different frequencies
this is advantageous to measure the sc
effects so here's a plot
of the tse effect in black the kse
effect in red
and here the kosc effect has been scaled
by a factor of 10 so you can see it
better
it's a very small effect the the fact
that we're taking temperature
differences to get at this pairwise
motion
helps us in measuring it because it is
averaging out due to the subtraction of
the two different temperature signals
that t is the effect and other
contaminating factors like dust
so i'll talk about that more later it's
also a statistical method which means if
we have many galaxies to look at we can
improve
our detection but measuring in multiple
frequencies will help us both
in constraining the the effects
themselves as well as removing from
contaminating sources like dust
okay so why are we interested in
studying this at all um this plot shows
the power's velocity
of those galaxies like i was talking
about in the last slide
as a function of the separation distance
or how far they are from one another
you can see there's a peak in this
velocity at separation distances
between about 20 and 40 omega parsecs
and this gives us
an indication that on average these
galaxies are moving towards one another
due to the attractive force of gravity
now we're interested in making
careful measurements of the pairwise
velocity curve because this gives us
insight into open questions in cosmology
today
for example we know that massive
neutrinos affected the growth of
structure
in our universe in the simulation you
can see
what happens if you put no mass in
neutrinos
you get this clustering of matter due to
gravity that creates these overdense
regions in red
and under dense regions in blue but if
you put some mass into neutrinos now
these uh little i call them mass bandits
can run away with some of the mass early
in the universe's history because
they're free streaming relativistically
and so they wash out these over
densities and under densities and you
see kind of a
washed out version of what you see on
the right hand panel
and so measurements that are sensitive
to the large scale structure of the
universe can place
upper limits on the sum of the neutrino
masses by saying how much mass was was
ran away with early in the universe's
history
so we're interested in doing this you
can see how the pairwise velocity curve
will change
if we have different sums of masses in
the neutrinos
we're interested in learning about this
because it's an open question in the
neutrino standard model
we don't yet know if the third mass
eigenstate of the neutrinos is the
heaviest in the normal hierarchy or the
lightest in the inverted hierarchy
and by placing upper limits we'll have
the potential and
we're likely to determine the mass
hierarchy with cosmological measurements
in the next
few years but this will also give
valuable information to laboratory
experiments because the measurements
we're making are independent from the
lab experiments that are happening on
earth
and they will also help interpret the
lab experiment results
such as neutrinolist double beta decay
experiments which are looking for
whether or not the neutrino could be a
majorana fermion
and if the neutrino was a meyer on a
fermion there are interesting
implications involving cp violation that
could
enable this this leptogenesis early in
the universe's history that
might explain the matter antimatter
asymmetry that we observe in the
universe it's a large open question in
physics today
so there's a lot to be learned once we
can pin down
the the sneaky neutrino mass a bit
better
we can also start answering some
questions about dark energy
potentially you can see here how the
pairwise velocity curve is sensitive to
these parameters that i'll describe on
this slide with very many arrows
so we know that the universe is
experiencing this accelerated expansion
but we don't know why in lambda cedium
cosmology
we describe this dark energy with this
negative pressure that
is that is driving this expansion
we can write down this equation of state
for dark energy
and parametrize it in terms of these
parameters w naught and w a
in lambda cdm cosmology w naught is
taken to b minus one
and there is no time dependence in dark
energy so w a is zero
if we find by measurements such as this
one that
we have more consistent measurements
with a time evolving
kind of dark energy or if w naught is
not equal to minus one
then we have some hints that we might
not be dealing with the lambda cdm
cosmology
that we know today we can also look at
the matter density contrast in our
universe
and think about general relativity we
can
look at the early fluctuations in the
density of our universe and how they
evolved over time
this factor here is the growth factor
and we can write down the growth factor
as it evolves
in gr in terms of this logarithmic
linear growth rate f
where you take the logarithmic
derivative of the growth factor
and you can approximate that in terms of
the matter density to this growth index
gamma
the point here i'm glossing over all the
details of course
but the growth index in general
relativity is about 0.55 so if you find
some inconsistency with this
number we might have a clue that perhaps
some modified gravity
model might explain the physics of our
universe better than gr
so we can test general relativity by
making these measurements of pairwise
velocity
so i'll talk about measurements with act
in this talk act
of course is a six meter cmb telescope
on saratoga in chile
right at the same site that the simon's
observatory is being built
it's currently observing with tes
and the data sets that i'll talk about
today have been co-added with plonk
so i'll be focusing on this paper that
we
are now just about to publish in prd
we're at the end of the
revisions it's entitled the atacama
cosmology telescope
probing the baryon content of sdss dr15
galaxies
with the thermal and kinematics and
iozeldovich effects it's one of two
companion papers so the other companion
paper
is caliphate gallardo and myself at all
and this is now focusing on the pairwise
kinematic essie effect
so i'll present a little bit of the
pairwise ksc
measurements in this talk and discuss
the optical depth estimates that came
from those
but for the details of the ksc work i
encourage you to check out
this paper there's a rich heritage with
act measurements
for these sc measurements of course act
the south pole telescope and planck have
all made tsc and ksc measurements in cmb
datasets
if you're interested in more on tse
stacking and dust reconstruction and the
types of methods that
we're doing at in act data you can look
at brittany fuzia's paper
on the sc based masses and dust emission
from ir
cluster candidates in the sheila survey
megan gralla's paper
on sc effects in low frequency radio
sources
and sued all covering the redshift
distribution
and properties of act selected dusty
star-forming galaxies
for the pipelines that we've been
working on there are these early results
that
formed the path that we've been going
down handled all in 2011. 2011
wrote on a detection of tsc effects
in act data stacking on a matched
filtered
cmb map with about 2 600 galaxies
it's really cool to look back and see
how many galaxies
we were working with just some years ago
and how many more we have now
so in the paper that i'll be talking
about today we have over 340 000
galaxies to work with
now in 2012 handheld reported the first
measurement of the kse effect
using act data this is the pairwise
momentum curve now so for the rest of
the talk
i won't be plotting power's velocity
like i showed in the the previous slides
but instead we have power's momentum
we're interested in measuring optical
depths of these halos because we want to
get to peris velocity in order to do
the cosmology that i just advertised and
in order to do that we need to break the
degeneracy with tau
so right now we're working with momentum
you can see there's a
dip here um we have better signal to
noise so the dip becomes more apparent
in the next few slides but that dip
corresponds to that
peak and velocity which again these
these objects are moving towards each
other
at these characteristic scales so this
first of um
first detection of the ksc effect used
the pairwise estimator that i'll be
talking about
and in 2017 francesco di bernardes led
our effort
in measuring the ksc effect at higher
signal to noise in
act data using boss dr-11
this paper was the first time that i
measured the tse effect using stacking
and then looked at how those
measurements of
optical depth compared to the ksc
optical depth estimates and we found the
results encouraging i'll talk about them
a little bit more
but that's what paved the way for the
current measurements
and finally um in this paper
advertisement part of the talk i'd like
to point your attention to emanuel
emmanuel seanadall
and stefani amadeodoll because they're
doing complementary measurements of tsc
and ksc
effects in act data using the same maps
that we're working with
in the paper i'll talk about today using
a different
data set from boss these are the cmas
and low z samples
of galaxies and they use a velocity
reconstruction approach so it's a
different estimator than the pairwise
estimator
but it's still measuring the ksc effect
they have a slightly higher signal to
noise measurement
and it's complementary to our efforts so
we'll be working together
using different ksc estimators moving
forward
stefania's paper also focuses on
gas thermodynamics and presents the dust
corrections that we use in our work
in order to estimate some of this dusty
emission
using herschel data
okay so what are we doing this is an
overview
of the measurement principles that i'll
be talking about
in kind of the simplest form so we have
a cmb map
thanks to everybody at act making great
observations and map products for us to
use
we also have an optical survey so we're
using data from boss
this tells us where the galaxies are
these galaxies are luminous red galaxies
we take them to be proxies for the
centers of group and cluster halos
this is a good assumption it turns out
and they
tell us the so the position the
luminosity
the higher luminosity lrgs trace higher
mass halos so there's a relationship
between luminosity and mass that we can
use
and again remember that scaling higher
luminosity higher mass
larger compton y larger optical deaths
in general
and so then we also have the redshifts
and we use this in the pairwise
estimator in order to
reconstruct or not reconstruct in the
sense of the velocity reconstruction
method but
still do a geometrical argument in order
to give the pairwise momentum
of those galaxies so okay we know where
they are
so then we can stack on them which means
we draw a little box
take a sub-map around each of the
galaxies and average them together
this is the tse stacking when you do
that you see the shadow
show up in the stacked submap so this is
one of our luminosity bins
which means we have a selection of
galaxies
above a certain luminosity threshold and
you can see the sc effect appear by eye
we measure the tsc signal using aperture
photometry
which means we draw a disk and a ring
take the average in the disk
minus the average in the ring and that
gives you the tsc signal associated with
that
sample of galaxies for the kse estimator
we have the positions again associated
with the sources as well as their
redshifts and we can take the same
filter aperture photometry filter and
associate a temperature
in the position of that tracer galaxy
and then reconstruct their pairwise
momentum
okay so we have a tsd measurement we
want to get to optical depth
in order to estimate optical depth from
our compton y measurements
we use this um hydrodynamical simulation
from vitalia in 2017.
this gives a relationship between the
optical depth tau of the gas
and the constant y of the gas using a
variety of different
subgrid physics models we take the model
that
we think best describes our sample and
we go from compton y to optical
depth the maps we're working with are
either in compton mile already or
they're in temperature units and if
they're in temperature units
we use this relationship which depends
on observation frequency to get to
compton y
so eventually we get to optical depth
from the tse and we can compare it to
the optical depth from the ksc
so this shows how we did that in 2017.
we had a smaller overlap with a smaller
map
and we used the dr-11 sample instead of
the dr-15 that we're working with now
this gave us about 68 000 sources
overlapping with the map
and you can see them in green
this is a histogram showing the number
of sources per redshift bin
you can compare it to the previous
results in hand at all and the smaller
sample of galaxies that we had to work
with
back then and this again is pales in
comparison to the many hundreds of
thousands of sources we have now and
things will only continue to improve in
the future which is exciting
so this gave us a four sigma measurement
of the ksc effect we use the pairwise
estimator again
these data points are what we measured
they're plotting
the pairwise momentum of the clusters as
a function of their separation distance
and then we do a fit um with a model
this is that the black line that you're
seeing
and that fit returns optical depth as a
free parameter
setting the amplitude here so once we
have that
fit we have tau and then we can
compare tau from tsc versus tau from kse
and in an ideal world we'd love to see
these data points
on a straight line with a slope of one
we fit to the independent data points in
dark blue
and found that the slope was consistent
with one
within our relatively large
uncertainties
so today we have larger maps these are
the act and plonk coated maps
they contain data from act taken between
2008 and 2018
and we're co-adding that data with data
from planck in the 2015 and 2018
releases
i mentioned previously but this covers
three frequencies at
100 150 into 220 gigahertz
and in cigarettes paper um
we also identify 4000 sc clusters
and over 18 000 point source candidates
so this figure shows two of the
frequencies that are available
these maps are publicly available on
lambda for anybody to work with
and it shows the planck data in black
and white and then the act
observation regions in the colored
outlines
and the contours that are in dark red
show the the deepest regions of act
observations
these are again deep regions of
observations plotted
in in this map here we call them they
used to be boss north but i i think now
they're just bn
and uh d56 which used to be deep five
six
so these are just deep observation
regions and in
matt's paper we describe how we can
component separate these maps using an
internal
linear combination approach to separate
out things like compton y
from the cmb and make maps of cmb plus
ksc
these two products are what we used in
our work to measure the sc effects we
use compton wire for the tsc
measurements and cmd plus kse for the
ksc measurements
and so these are the regions that are
available for those maps
so now this is from our paper showing
a cropped version of the co-added map
overlapping with our
sdss sample so the blue points over
plotted here
show the entire sample of galaxies that
we used after
a series of cuts we did a noise map cut
so we're focusing only on the overlap
with the the deepest regions
and those are plotted in purple here
we also did a galactic plane mask using
the galactic plane mask from plonk that
was
the 2015 compton y map production
and we did a point source mask using the
same point source masks that were used
in
other act analysis before
the blue shows overlap with that deep
region d56 for the component separated
map analysis
and the green shows overlap with the bn
region again for the component-separated
map analysis
so because these deeper regions are
smaller area
we have slightly fewer sources in those
regions
so i showed this histogram previously
and said that it pales in comparison to
our sources here so that's what you can
see in this histogram
now in blue we're showing the full
sample that was available to us as well
as the selected sample
in the dark blue step and comparing it
to what we had to work with in 2017
our on average we had sources that were
lrgs that had redshifts of about 0.5
so we worked with the 150 and 98
gigahertz coated maps as well as the
component separated maps
and after the cuts we had 343 000
sources
covering 3 3 700 square degrees of sky
this is the table that summarizes the
luminosity bins that we worked with
so we had five cumulative and five
disjoint luminosity bins for the tsc
work
the specific luminosity cuts shown here
were chosen based off of the 2017 work
for consistency
and then we chose three equally spaced
bins for the joint analysis between the
ksc and the tsc work
and so we chose these bins to have about
100 000 sources per bin
the asterisks here are showing which
bins are analyzed between the two com
the two companion papers and then these
higher luminosity bins were included for
the tse analysis because they'll have
the higher signal to noise measurements
of the toc effect
but the number of galaxies per bin is
too small for high signal to noise
measurements of the ksc effect
so they weren't included included in
their ksc measurements
so this table shows luminosity selection
cuts
the corresponding mass thresholds and
stellar masses
of those bins as well as the number of
sources per bin
average luminosity average redshift and
you can see that there are fewer sources
per bin like i mentioned
for the component-separated maps
otherwise known as the dr4
ilc maps than there are in the co-added
maps
so i'll briefly talk about the pairwise
ksc estimator
on this slide it's a statistical method
again to extract the ksc
effect we use an aperture photometry
filter
with the disk radius chosen to be 2.1
arc minutes
based on the red shift of our sample and
this gives a temperature
signal associated with each source again
taking the average of the disk minus the
average of the ring
we know that this temperature signal is
proportional to the line of state
momentum
of that gas and then we use the redshift
information from our
catalog to plug into this geometrical
factor c
which gives us the pairwise velocity as
a function or peri's momentum excuse me
as a function of the separation distance
and so the pairs are coming out of this
uh subtraction so you have i
and j these are summing over different
pairs on the sky and that difference
here is what is
averaging out contamination from tsc
effect and dust
so you sum over these pairs of galaxies
that share similar separation
each one of those separation bins is one
of those data points plotted in the
pairwise momentum curve
this text here is discussing how we
selected our sub maps to be 18 by 18 arc
minutes
and we worked with originally a pixel
size of half an arc minute
until we re-pixelized to 0.1 arc minutes
per pixel and then reprojected
to a coordinate system centered at the
galaxy center position using pixel
so these are some of those results the
pairwise momentum
is plotted as a function of separation
distance for the three different maps
studied the black points are the
component-separated cmb
plus kse maps the blue points are the
component separated
or i'm sorry the co-added 150 gigahertz
map the orange or the co-added
98 gigahertz map and each of these
panels is for a different luminosity
sample
so this is the higher luminosity bin and
then this
is the lower luminosity bin but these
are cumulative so the lower luminosity
bin is for the full sample
so when you're looking at this you might
notice that the uncertainties are larger
for the bottom panel
this is because when we're dealing with
a smaller number of sources since it's a
statistical method we have a larger
uncertainty
when we have a higher number of sources
those error bars are smaller
however you can also notice that the dip
in the full sample is a bit shallower
than the dip we see
at the higher luminosities and that's
because we have a higher signal
associated
with these higher luminosity higher mass
sources so there's a balance here
between
the luminosity of the sample and the
number of sources per sample
so all together we made a 5.4 sigma
detection of the pairwise ksc effect
by doing fits to these data points we
obtain estimates of optical depth
and you can see that here tau
comes into play as i mentioned before
this plot shows the different bins
studied with that effect of larger
uncertainties with smaller
numbers of sources overall we were
seeing consistent values across the maps
so now we wanted to compare tau from ksc
with tao from tsc
in order to get there we stack on these
sub maps
each sub map plotted here is a different
luminosity bin
the top two rows are the 98 gigahertz
coed the bottom two
are the compton y um compton y is the
component separated map
note here that this is negative constant
y because
um i wanted to just show intuitively by
eye that it's it's a shadow but constant
y is
is a positive quantity so this sign was
was flipped
to plot these sub maps we did the same
aperture photometry with the 2.1 arc
minute radius
as the ksc measurements and this was an
improvement over our 2017 work
in which we used a matched filter for
the tse measurements but not for the ksc
measurements so now that's consistent
and we estimated the uncertainties
associated
with that quantity using a jackknife
error bar
estimate method
the little clouds that i drew along
these uh names of luminosity bin
indicate the joint tse and ksc analysis
and you can see by eye that the higher
luminosity bins which are on the left
have a higher signal to noise even just
by eye the shadows are
are darker than if you look at the lower
luminosity bins
in which the sc signal almost disappears
just to your eye
it's still there but it's smaller
signals to noise
we had cumulative bins as well as
disjoint bins
and the disjoint bins are independent
bins from one another so they don't
share
sources in common and those are plotted
as the second
row of stacks here
this is the 150 cohen and i'd like to
note that you can see this central
bright spot appearing
which we attribute to dust and you can
see it by eye
in many of the bins appearing at small
scales
within that disk that we used for
aperture photometry
and so we wanted to investigate that a
bit further
this plot shows that
only the 150 gigahertz co-added data in
the paper you can see this for
every map that we studied it gives the
radial average of the stacked submap so
this is the center of the stub map and
then you just run a radiate
radial average out and normalize to the
average value within
the annulus the black dashed line is the
disc radius
and the solid black line is the annulus
radius
and then we would expect the sc effect
to
just continue to have the the strongest
decrement or highest signal right at the
center of the sub map
but we are seeing here just like in the
previous slide
this central bright spot appearing as an
increment in temperature
at the beam scale or below
so we were considering whether or not
our herschel dust estimate that we
applied later
was sufficient to remove this
contamination and in order to study that
we have this plot here this is showing
the tsc signal
as in temperature for the co-added maps
scaled by a frequency dependent factor
to better can
compare the two frequencies the
frequency dependent factor
is written here and the text
so the filled circles are the raw
results that we just get from stacking
the blue is at 150. the orange is at 98.
the triangles are what happens after we
correct for dust using
herschel data so we stack on the same
positions of these galaxies
in three different observation
frequencies and
herschel data in order to estimate the
dust emission that's present there then
we correct for that
the details are in stefania amadeo's
paper
and then i cut out just the central beam
scale
of the submaps in the open circles to
see what we would see
and this confirmed that within one sigma
of our herschel corrected
numbers this just complete removal of
the central
section of the map didn't didn't bias
our results
past one sigma so we didn't proceed with
including this we would also need to
carefully correct for that
if we were to remove that central region
because that's where we expect
a lot of our tse signal to be located
anyway
so in the future it might be important
to keep an eye on this
but with our current level of
uncertainties we don't need to proceed
with removing
the rest of that contamination
this table shows the dust estimates from
herschel data and you can just see that
the numbers are small
um so we are dealing with with
temperature signals that are i don't
know here's just a number
0.8 and here for that most luminous bin
you can look at here and you have a dust
correction that's
0.04 so it's a it's a small change and
that's why you see the triangles
being quite consistent with the filled
circles in this plot
this table shows the tse results in
summary
each of the luminosity bins is written
down along with the
tse signal and temperature units and in
compton y
for the two coordinated maps as well as
the native compton y units for the
component separated map
so we found that the measurements were
consistent across the three maps
and i think it's probably easier just to
look at the plot version of that table
this shows the disjoint bins as well as
the full sample
and plots compton y and signal to noise
for each of these bins you can see now
by eye that they're consistent and you
can see that our highest signal to noise
measurements
were in the higher luminosity bins as we
would have expected
so now we have compton y and we want
optical depth so this is where we employ
that hydrazine relationship
this gives a relationship between tau
optical depth and compton y
we choose the parameters that best
describe our sample
based on the redshift of that sample
and then we report that data in this
large table
so this table gives the luminosity bins
again
this table at the beginning of the table
is the 150 gigahertz quad the 90
gigahertz coed and the component
separated map on the bottom
the second column is theoretical tau and
that's
the uh the estimate that we made based
on theory assuming
a navarro frank white profile this is
telling you how we expect
that the density and the content
of both baryonic and dark matter to
fall off with radius if the baryons were
to trace the dark matter in that halo
so in that case you write down your
theoretical tau
use the estimate of the mass of these
halos based on their tracer galaxies and
come up with how much
optical depth we think we have within
our 2.1 arc aperture
in the aperture photometry and so that's
our theoretical towel that we can
compare our observations to
then we have our estimated tsc towel
a systematic error bar associated with
the
uncertainties on the physics models that
are present in the hydro sim
relationship
and the statistical uncertainty that's
present in the tsc measurements just
propagated through
to tau and then we have f
c f c is the fraction of theoretically
predicted baryon content as observed by
the tse
measurements so you can think of it as
just taking tau
from the tse divided by tau from theory
so if you had one
that would mean we see exactly the
theory number
then we report tau from kse these
numbers are
presented in caliphate at all from the
ksc estimator
and we do the same thing just taking the
fraction
tau kse over tau theory and that gives
you
fc so here's the plot version of that
table
now we're just plotting the three
disjoints of independent bins
of sources that were both studied in the
tse and ksc work
as well as the full sample fc is what's
plotted on the y-axis
this is the measurement over theory and
the full circles give
the tse results the open circles give
the kse results
so this is where we can start thinking
about how much of this optical
depth content or equivalently vary on
content
we're seeing compared to the theoretical
predictions
and because our uncertainties are large
we're not able to put
a tight constraints on the xperian
content but with future higher signal to
noise data we will be able to
right now we're seeing between about one
third to all
of the theoretically predicted baryon
content
and we find that the tse and kse results
are in agreement
in two out of the three bins that are
co-studied but in this higher
luminosity bin we see a difference at
two to three sigma
we're interested in understanding that a
bit better we can plot this in a
different way
this is now plotting tau from the ksc
measurements
against y from the tse measurements and
this removes that the hydrosim
relationship
from the tsc measurements instead we can
overplot that hydrosyn relationship
in this green line in order to just
compare theory to experiment
our data points are plotted with the
typical colors for
black is the component separated result
orange 90 gigahertz
blue 150 and these are again
only the disjoint bins that i compared
on the previous slide
you can see that the the observations
agree with the theory
within the one sigma error bar and the
theory presented as the
shaded region and again the highest
luminosity
data point is low in the ksc what we
would like to do
is expand out this high luminosity data
point
into sub bins so we can plot more data
points
because there's of course a great deal
of correlation
between the maps that were used since
they're the same data products
so we can't do that because right now we
have about 100 000 sources
in this l79 bin if we were to subdivide
it into
fewer numbers of sources the high signal
to noise we have in the ksc
would go away because we need large
numbers of galaxies in order to make
this statistical measurement
so in the future we'll have larger data
sets to work with and we'll be able to
have more data points
in mass to plot and so we can look at if
there's actually a mass dependent
relationship here
or if this is just kind of an outlier
because it is only at two to three sigma
so that's something that we are
interested in following up with now and
are currently working on for
future data sets
um actually before i go to the
systematics discussion i do want to
mention that this is
exciting because it's the first step
towards an empirical whitetail
relationship
we currently have only been working with
theory models we have simulations we can
do based on different feedback
mechanisms
galaxies to tell us how these things are
going to evolve
and this is really a first step towards
using just measurements alone in order
to
feed back no pun intended into the to
the feedback models
and inform theory with measurements and
and see how we're doing in terms of our
theoretical predictions there
so in the future it'll be exciting to
see what comes out from that
okay so now systematics discussion the
herschel dust corrections that we
employed
partially addressed the source galaxy
emission but as we saw there's some
residual dust contamination
right now it's less than one sigma but
in the future it could be important so
it's
it'll be something to keep an eye on for
future stacking efforts
we used a galactic plane mask for the
synchrotron emission which is
sufficient for our purposes but future
work is going to improve on this
by modeling and removing this dust and
synchrotron emission
from the tracer galaxies we'll be able
to do this with high frequency
measurements and multi-frequency
measurements and we're going to make
really great
constraints on the dust and synchrotron
emission in the future
for both this kind of science effort and
also other science efforts
in this work we also estimated a two
halo term
this is um the correction to the
assumption that we're only seeing one
halo
per aperture in fact there could be some
additional halo that's present in that
aperture right now that contribution
is again found to be less than one sigma
but um
in a similar vein to everything else i
keep saying it's going to be important
to correct for
with higher signal to noise work the
details of the two halo correction are
also instafania amadeo's paper
if anybody's interested in that and in
the future it will be important
to carefully consider the mass
luminosity relationship that we looked
at in this work
as well as to understand the samples in
your simulations
so we could improve upon our comparisons
to sims
by expanding the mass range in the
simulations lower
since we dealt with so many lower mass
groups than we did high mass clusters
so both um
correct overlap between the samples used
in measurements to theory
as well as uncertainty propagation in
the samples
between mass and luminosity are
important to consider for the future
so speaking of the future um so is
happening i'm pretty sure you're all
making that happen right now with epoxy
and other things
the work that i'm talking about here is
forming the basis of the esso pairwise
ksc pipeline
for measurements with the large aperture
telescope
we have the ksc code live
and the tlc code is coming up i just uh
i've been a little distracted with my
thesis but now
i'll be able to get that live online um
of course the pipeline has been
validated on real map data since it was
just uh published on
and discussed in this work and in these
papers we did checks
using some simulations of noise for null
tests
and we'll be continuing to test the
pipeline and refine it over time for so
so in the next steps we're going to be
exploring that trend of luminosity
and hopefully one day using the tse
measurements directly for
looking at pairwise velocities which
will be really exciting because it will
start to probe neutrino mass
and dark energy and other items of
interest
and we'll also have an empirical
quadtile relationship that we can
compare to simulations
so that's all restated on the slide
essentially
um i think on the next slide yes i have
some constraints
some predictions these are a little bit
older but they still show
how much better we're going to be doing
in the future using ksc information from
a cnb
s4 effort combined with information from
plonk and from
lensing and red these constraints are
now drilling down on the parameter space
of the sum of the neutrino masses and
the matter density and dark energy
equation estate parameters
this plot from the cmv s4 science book
shows how much better we're going to do
when we add in ksc information
to these clustering and red shift space
distortion predictions
using desi so that's the blue line we'll
be
we'll be making better measurements of
sigma 8 and
the logarithmic linear growth rate f
and that's without an informative prior
on tau so now tau is not just the
optical depth associated with a
galaxy halo but is the optical depth um
period optical depth to the to the
photons that we're studying
and if we do make um better measurements
of tau from independent sources
we'll be able to improve our ksc
measurements so this is a an overarching
trend where
for better ksc measurements pairwise ksc
measurements we need optical depth
information
and in the future for other ksc
measurements we'll still need optical
depth information so hopefully the tsd
effect will be useful there
and now i don't know what time it is do
i have a little bit more time to to plug
cat
yeah yeah it's still it's 11 56 and
we're not on the like the superstars
okay cool so now this is just a plug for
the upcoming work that i'll be working
on now as a postdoc
um the feast the fred young
sub-millimeter telescope is basically a
lot
it's a lot at a higher site it'll be on
cerro cha-chan tour
this will open high-frequency windows
and we'll be observing with mkids
these high-frequency observations are
going to complement
so science as well as other cnb science
will be able to characterize dust at a
variety of high frequencies
and make excellent sc measurements with
with the feast
we'll be using prime cam as our first
generation science instrument
you can think of it as a little a small
ladder
so it has instrument modules that are so
sized and we're working based off of the
esso design
in order to to make them right now
prime cam will be able to hold seven of
them and it's a similar design to the
latr if you're familiar with it
where these are cantilevered off of the
4k plate
right now prime cam is currently being
fabricated
and we're working towards the fabric
para interferometry that will enable
our spectroscopic observations as well
as making the first instrument modules
these are going to be tested in mod cam
so modcam is a first light instrument
for c-cap prime it will be a
single module test bed for prime cam
once prime cam is ready for a deployment
it has a dr offset to the side so
whereas for
prime cam we have a dr right in the
center you need to remove it in order to
swap out your instrument modules
here we can just swap the instrument
modules in and out the back
um it can have the so uh read out
harness
inserted or custom readout like we're
working with right now
and again it's it's compatible with so
models so i'm working with
bob u pen in order to make the first
module
here's another schematic of it now we've
done dunk
tests of the absorbing tiles the same
plastic ones that were
modeled for the mold at penn and we're
currently assembling it
and we're going to be deploying the
first light array at 280 gigahertz using
mkids
so we're currently testing that array
um so in the future we're going to be
able to open up these high frequency
windows
and enable excellent sd science and in
the future future for cmbs4 we could
potentially put a
even larger diameter cryostat holding up
to 19
prime cam style modules or even more
smaller diameter modules on the feast
at this really excellent high elevation
site
so thank you and i'm really happy to
take any questions
brian wants to know prospects on
measuring the polarized sc effect
someday
oh that's a great question i don't have
any
um numbers in hand for that i haven't
looked at forecasts for that
um i i'm it might be kind of just
lip service to say it'll get better um
but of course all of these measurements
are going to be
characterizing contaminating effects and
enabling multi-frequency measurements to
enable those but that's a good question
i'd i'd love to look at some numbers
and uh forecasts for that
i gotta run brian i'm just saying you
need to run and thanks
okay thank you brian congratulations
thank you i got a question
yeah so i do appreciate you uh at least
uh showing the sat on these slides
uh know your audience
this isn't even something i've thought
of and obviously it's not our science
case
but out of curiosity would is a half
meter aperture
telescope even be able to detect that
question
i have not i don't think so right we're
looking at arc minute scales
photons are green but the beam is well
very smoothed out
i don't think we'll be using the sats
for any high resolution
it's just a question of whether we'd be
able to see it or not at all
i don't think you'll be able to see it i
mean if you look at planck right
um in the early plots that the clusters
don't show up because it just lacked the
resolution
that's kind of right we appreciate it
well on the a good a nice thing is that
with with the feast and
these high frequency observations that
will help the science will also really
help
um the the search for from radial
gravitational waves by
controlling for the dust that you guys
need to be controlled for
so we're helping you
thanks hey
nice
sorry i didn't quite hear that oh they
were just saying virginia and ethan here
have heard of the sc effect so um
hopefully they got at least you know
some of the talks
cutting edge yeah i i did have one
question on that plot of the compton y
parameter versus optical depth
um i wonder if if you just have like a
heuristic physical explanation for why
theoretically at the straight line
and like you know what would it
physically mean if that
cluster on the far right is in fact you
know at that lower optical depth value
well i mean if if we say okay the theory
is wrong the experiment's right then
whatever fit we do to this would just be
a slightly different
model the model parameters that come out
when you do that
fit aren't too super drastically
different
um than the parameters that show this
line as
it currently stands just because of how
the math works if we go back
here to what this looks like in terms of
the original model
this is optical depth versus why there's
some scatter
but basically this is telling you that
the higher mass
gas is more optically dense and
the relationships that are fit here are
the simulations that
are taking into account different types
of models so
for example the non-radiant model in
green which seems kind of disparate from
the other ones
i understand to be a less realistic
circumstance like obviously there is
radiation i guess there is radiative
cooling and then these other things that
are happening
um in galaxy evolution that i'm not an
expert on but are probably
present and making this non-radiative
case more extreme
so we worked with the agn feedback model
which is considered to be more realistic
you can tune these parameters and come
out with
slightly different whitetail
relationships and so
maybe there would be some implication
then if
the theory here was incorrect and this
higher mass spin
was indeed where it is currently
so basically the fits that we could make
to high signal to noise data
would inform the simulations and the
physics models there and might glean
some insight into the future
but right now we can't say anything
strong about that
sure sure you know that makes sense
thanks i mean yeah just looking at that
maybe is there any talk about like
different
processes are important at different
halo masses
so that like that's how you might get
this turnover if it really exists
there hasn't been a discussion on
different mass halos having
different physics involved i don't
think that would be the main explanation
here
um i think it would probably be just a
difference
in um of course if they're if it's not a
straight line after all yeah then then
you're entering some regime that i'm not
i'm not sure about sure yeah i'd rather
not speculate about different physics
that may or may not exist
um but it'll be really interesting to
constrain uh with more data
yeah no no that's fair okay yeah thanks
a quick question um when you're showing
the
the plots with the circles and the uh
there's that shadow and you're able to
see dust
yeah i
missed how you're able oh uh sorry uh
a couple slides back i think um
yeah these um i was actually confused
how you're able to
figure out that this would
be dust i guess i didn't fully
understand why some values were
negative and how you're able to
determine that versus
the dust valleys that make sense yeah
definitely um
we expect the sc signal to appear as
um a decrement um
meaning so these submaps are plotted to
the average within the annulus
um so they're normalized here so
the dark spot indicates a decrement in
temperature that is the tsc effect
showing up because of the shift in the
black body spectrum
so anything that's an increment um
instead of a decrement at this frequency
is probably a source of emission
and dust is a source of emission which
means it would add
add to the temperature we're seeing
rather than take away from it in terms
of the sc effect
so when we're seeing a bright spot
appearing instead of a dark spot
um that's telling us that it's emission
and not um
not the sc effect which is what we're
trying to measure
cool yeah i appreciate it yeah i i
totally missed there was
it was a decrement yeah it makes sense
cool yeah and it's just at that
frequency so if we were looking at
something above 220 we're looking at 300
gigahertz um we would be looking for an
increment
and not a decrement so that's why it's
it's useful to measure the sc effect at
multiple frequencies
because if you do you'll be able to
learn more about what
the dust might be in your maps
cool yeah thank you
any other questions from anyone on zoom
all right maybe maybe we'll call it
there it's a little bit after
noon so um i guess last chance
questions okay well thanks a lot if this
was uh pretty great
i really appreciate you coming on thank
you so much it was great to see
everybody in a um
a semi-in-person seminar
that's really neat yeah it's one of our
first ones we've done like this
so yeah let's probably get the gang back
together
awesome all right well good luck with
all of the uh
the epoxying thanks good luck with your
uh
postdoc thank you all right hope to see
you soon
see ya